what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today the first
trailer for obi-wan hello there but
before we go into that i want to say a
special thank you to a sponsor we have
loved working with this past month and
that is the diss plate sometimes i just
stand back there and admire that poster
for you art lovers out there diss plate
makes gorgeous prints on durable metal
sheets that are super easy to install
display and swap out and they've over a
million designs in their stores ranging
from independent artists to some of our
favorite ips like star wars dc and
marvel and you won't need any power
tools to install them thanks to
displaced magnet based mounting system
takes all of about 20 seconds to install
we also got spidey on the wall here and
since john's a big horror fan we also
got this awesome trick-or-treat display
which will not be hung here we don't do
that elsewhere disc plate plants a tree
for each one you buy and they ship to 56
countries worldwide so hit our special
link in the description box and save
yourself 23
on your first one or two displays or
save 27 when you grab three or more
support stem supports the channel
supports you and seems like you're not
living in some like blank colorless void
in your life now on to the video
the fight is done
we lost
kenobi of arabia
rookie
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh they're compassionate oh damn
uncle owen
the jedi code is like an itch
oh my goodness
this looks great
[Music]
[Laughter]
holy bolts
ah the lightsaber on the eye it's good
it's a good touch
nice comes out when a new hope was
originally released in 1937 we got to
travel back in order to see it
that's good marketing
that looks great that looks really so it
seems like that vader dispatched the
inquisitors to go find obi-wan
specifically yeah he's bitter unless
there's a mislead here with the trailer
we're gonna like no i think my son's out
there
don't let him get away go kill that kid
that looked awesome that looked like a
movie absolutely like a move was
but yeah this looks more vital and more
lived in after they start playing duel
of the fates that was beautiful
absolutely beautiful to bring it full
circle with the first appearance from
obi-wan kenobi's even mcgregor and then
now to have his show a series that we've
been wanting for so long imported
chapter in his life now we got the
inquisitor showing up here first time in
live action if i'm not mistaken so if
you guys watch rebels or played star
wars jedi fallen order you will be
familiar with the inquisitors obviously
they are like people who are dispatched
to hunt down jedi who survived after
order 66 or hunt down force sensitive
children i remember even playing a jedi
fallen order i think it was the second
sister yes i forgot her actual name took
me
like four hours to beat her i had to
stop playing it and then continue the
next day did it in 30 minutes there you
go that's the plot leak for how this is
going to end when he fights
this show in 30 minutes
i'm going to take a break we'll come
back tomorrow i'm gonna beat you then
fresh eyes and then with the grand
inquisitor uh he is hailed as like just
right behind darth vader in terms of
like most powerful you know he's he's
extremely powerful i would recommend
just going to watch rebels i won't talk
spoilers about it but it's exciting to
have him here there's a really big
threat in rebels he's badass to behold
jason isaac's voiced them in the
animated series now to see him brought
to live action is just so neat and they
even got the specific types of unique
lightsabers the spinning ones oh yeah
that looked cool and then so here it
looks like the main villain tasked to
hunting down uh it looks like at least
the trailer saying the one to hunt down
obi-wan is gonna be reba i thought she'd
have a helmet or something i always
associate them with having helmets you
do see them in their quarters at one
point where it looks like you're gonna
see some of the other inquisitors as
well who we've seen in rebels more
importantly i mean just what this looks
like it's just it looks like cinematic
as [ __ ] like it looks beautiful i like
seeing like the the little bits of
obi-wan that we got like when he's
watching luke at the beginning who's
like i'm going to be a pilot one day ah
and then obi-wan's look at him like i've
seen this before yes yes i remember
being here tattooing
second one kid
racing he's just like his pups also with
the sort of um despairing portrayal that
we have here of uncle owen with joel
edgerton reprising his role i imagine
that this will also explore what
ultimately led to them having this like
tension between them because as we saw
in a new hope the way how uncle owen
describes him he calls him like a crazy
old wizard you know when you actually
catch up with obi-wan in that film when
luke brings up the name obi-wan kenobi
obi-wan responds in a way like i haven't
heard that name
oh my god i forgot all about him so i
think we're going to be seeing you know
a this transition from obi-wan just
fully succumbing to becoming ben kenobi
where he has you know lost so much sight
of his former self maybe perhaps i don't
know it's a very specific chapter we'll
also see what led to uncle owen
completely mistrusting or wanting
nothing to do with obi-wan like i i
think what will happen is through these
series of events uncle owen would
ultimately find obi-wan's presence to be
a threat to luke's safety yeah with
everything that he brings with him and
i'm curious to see how that played that
because i mean hearing the description
that we're gonna join obi-wan in a state
where he is more disparate and he is
more faithless i believe as the press
brief uh puts it that hearkens to me to
the idea that they went with for luke in
the last jedi which i can't imagine
they'll do here so i'm curious to see
how they change that flavor because also
i mean evan mcgregor is one of the best
actors to grace a star wars movie uh
because you know i mean sometimes the
acting isn't always the best or the most
you know enlivened and i feel like he
has the perfect blend for this world
where he can fit perfectly in with like
the elements of the star wars acting
flavor that you associate but also
really bring that pathos and that
gravitas and whatnot like to see this
middle chapter i'm curious to know how
they will you know embolden the stakes
because we know that luke little luke is
not going to fall into the wrong hands
probably at least not for long if he
does that's the big question mark for me
now is how are they going to make this
middle chapter vital and i hope they do
that via you know a strong character
study of this you know titular character
who's supposed to have a movie focused
on him and now a show i feel like is
even better because you can dig into all
those layers and bring in all your cool
other star wars you know uh inquisitor
characters and whatnot well it's
reported to be six episodes and each one
is going to be at least an hour long
that's what was reported it looked like
at one point here that they would go off
tattooing at some point or maybe it
isn't tattooing i'm not sure they've
hyped up a place called daiyu which is
supposed to have like yeah like a
criminal nightlife and it's supposed to
be very neon washed and edgy it's like
major poor exactly like madrid
star wars drappor i think deborah chao
said it was like a a city out of hong
kong based off hong kong yeah i think
this looks awesome deborah chow the work
that she's done in star wars already has
been
phenomenal i can't wait to see this show
you best bet we're going to be doing
reactions to it guys what'd you think
about the obi-wan trailer leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click the
notification bell major things to
display for sponsoring this video helps
get around that duel of the fates
copyright claim
but before we leave let's do a pic
we're gonna keep this straight to the
point michael b go michael b if if we're
gonna be covering this show you can bet
michael b is gonna be covering this show
so michael hey prep yourself the star
wars fans are coming and if you're a
star wars fan has made to this point in
the video go subscribe to omni media and
keep an eye out for his reactions just
make sure that you watch them after you
watch our reactions because we sense you
that's the hierarchy of things michael b
he's got great insights he knows the
world he is an expert and a nerd on the
highest level of the highest order we
love him and uh hey buddy we'll catch
you soon thanks for being here yeah
[Music]
you